Professor Donald
Kagan: I have a title for
today's talk.
I call it, "Philip,
Demosthenes and the Fall of the
Polis," and I read that to you
because it's always useful to
remember that while we look back
on these events and know their
outcome and can assign to them a
special significance,
let's never forget they didn't
know that they were on the brink
of the end of the independent
polis.
In fact, I'm sure if you came
along in 362 after that battle
it would never have occurred to
you that that whole fundamental
arrangement of the world that
had been sort of in place,
to some degree,
perhaps as far back as the
eighth century was going to
change its character very
sharply,
and that although there would
still be poleis that
would be going on,
it might seem in the same old
way, even after the Macedonian
conquest, the fact was that none
of them ever again really was
autonomous in the sense of to be
fully in control of its own fate
both in terms of the internal
constitution and also,
more importantly or at least
the one that was most in danger,
the capacity to engage in
international relations freely
and to be free to make their own
foreign policy.
So, as I say,
it's going to be a very major
change but it's something that
they don't know they're in the
middle of watching.
Well, in 359 a man called
Philip became King of Macedon.
We know the Macedonians were
fundamentally Greeks.
That is to say,
they were Greek speakers and
ethnically, if there is such a
thing, they were Greek.
But they were so far out of the
mainstream of the development of
the Greek poleis that we
have been examining this
semester that many,
many Greeks,
perhaps most of them,
didn't think of them as being
Greek.
When Greeks thought about what
it was to be a Greek they
thought about more than the fact
that they spoke the Greek
language,
they thought fundamentally--if
you get to Aristotle you see how
thoroughly true this is,
it had to do with a culture,
a way of life and that way of
life was based upon the
independent polis.
Well, Macedon did not have
such a structure.
The Greeks called the
Macedonians an ethnos,
a tribal group is what that
sort of means.
We use the word "nation"
somehow to translate
ethnos and that's okay.
The word "nation" itself,
you remember,
comes from the Latin word which
means to be born;
people who are born of the same
stock.
But for the Greeks it had a
different meaning;
it was people who participated
in the culture that they
designated as Hellenic and they
thought the Macedonians fell
outside of that.
There were no poleis in
the Macedonian kingdom.
It was something that we might
call feudal.
That is to say,
yes there was a monarch,
but there were powerful
noblemen who were practically
independent and who owed only a
limited allegiance to the king
and who were really the dominant
figures in the state for most of
the history prior to the
appearance of Philip.
On the other hand,
the king was an important and
powerful character so that you
have--this was true of European
feudal states at certain periods
in their development.
On the one hand,
the fundamental society was
based upon great lords,
great noblemen,
barons, but there was a king
and he was not inconsequential.
That's the situation that
pertained in Macedon.
In a certain sense,
if a Greek had looked at
Macedonian society prior to
Philip,
he might have described it as
Homeric, and you'll be familiar
with that.
Sure, there were guys called
basileus,
but they were not really the
rulers over the barons,
these great noblemen in their
kingdom.
They thought of it as
uncivilized in the technical
sense.
If you don't live in a
polis,
a city, as they understood it,
then you are not civilized;
you are part of an
ethnos and that's the
term they used of the tribal
societies all around them,
Illyrians, Scythians,
they were all from an
ethnos.
The Macedonians,
on the other hand,
claimed very proudly and
powerfully, and insistently that
they were Greeks;
they were Hellenes,
and they probably invented a
myth of their descent.
Indeed, not merely from Greeks
but from the real Greeks,
that is to say the Argives,
who were the leading people in
the time of Homer's poetry and
they claimed direct descent from
Agamemnon and the other Argive
kings.
We hear about various
Macedonian monarchs of some
importance prior to Philip,
back at the time of the Persian
War, Alexander the first played
an interesting and shady role
between the Greeks and the
Persians.
During the Peloponnesian War we
hear of a King Perdiccas,
who also played a role shifting
between the Spartans and the
Athenians.
This business of shifting
between sides is not just
because they're shifty people.
It's that their status is such
that they're always vulnerable
and not powerful enough to
defend themselves and so they
have to make the best deal they
can with whoever has the power
at any moment.
One other Macedonian king has
left a name that we know
something about,
Archelaus,
who followed Perdiccas,
one of the things about him was
that he kept a kind of a
cultural court at his capital,
and for instance Euripides,
for reasons that we do not
know, left Athens at some point
in the Peloponnesian War and
came to Macedon where he joined
a collection of artists and
scholars,
and whatever that Archelaus was
gathering in his kingdom.
Well, Philip becomes king in
359 and the Macedonian kings
were very much like Homeric
kings as we have described them
here.
That is, yes you had to have a
dynastic claim,
you had to be a member of the
royal family to be king,
but that wasn't good enough.
You had to also have--remember,
to rule as I said about the
Homeric kings,
iphi,
by force, by power,
you had to have the actual
capacity to command and
sometimes you had to demonstrate
that by fighting it out among
various potential successors
with having the winner coming
out as the king.
Something like that is what
Philip did.
He was not the most direct
descendant of the previous king.
He was left as a kind of a
regent over the under-aged young
king of just a boy and he was
actually Philip's nephew and
Philip's ward,
and Philip took care of him in
more senses than one,
finally killing him and
replacing him on the throne.
That was not a unique event
in Macedonian history.
So, Philip is now on the throne
and, of course,
with this disputed descent,
this disputed right to the
throne,
you can imagine that he is not
in the most secure position when
he takes over this job,
and so I think some part of his
actions, certainly at the early
part of his career,
and perhaps all the way
through, was meant to
demonstrate his own greatness,
his own capacity to be king so
as to put down all resistance
internally and for that purpose
what could be better than
spreading the boundaries,
increasing the power,
and in making the greatness of
Macedon more than it had been
before and that's what he
undertook.
It looks as though,
I think we have enough evidence
to believe, that he certainly,
of course, meant to rule
Macedon and to do whatever was
necessary, however harsh to make
that secure.
But it is pretty clear that he
had it in mind to conquer
Greece, to make himself the
master of Greece.
That was certainly one of his
objectives.
As a matter of fact,
an interesting part of his
biography was that as a young
man--probably I should say as a
boy,
probably in his teens,
he was sent to Thebes as a
hostage as a result of a war
between the Thebans and the
Macedonians,
but he was treated as a member
of the royal family.
He was treated very decently
and with respect,
and he spent his time in the
house of Epaminondas.
Can you imagine a better place
for a young king with his
military ambitions to be brought
up than in the house of the man
who is surely the foremost
general in the Greece of his
time and perhaps of any time,
and I think we should imagine
that he must have learned a
great deal about military
affairs there.
There remains the question,
did Philip already have in his
mind the plan of conquering the
Persian Empire,
which was, of course,
the job that was completed by
his son, because whatever
Philip's intentions may have
been he died before he could
carry them out.
I don't think we can be certain
about that, but it was an idea
that he didn't have to do a lot
to dream up.
I've mentioned to you how many
an orator, Isocrates,
most famously,
had been calling on various
Greek states and individuals to
conquer the Persian Empire,
to solve Greece's problems,
and he wrote such a letter to
Philip once Philip became the
most powerful figure in that
world.
So, he certainly could have had
the idea;
I mean, he certainly did have
the idea--whether he was
planning to do that or not we
don't know.
Now, his first--sort of the
instrument that permitted him
and Macedon to become as great
as they did was the army that he
created.
I mean, it is very he who is
the revolutionary,
the military genius who creates
the weapon which will allow him
to conquer Greece,
and it's the same military
force that enables Alexander the
Great, who had brought to it
brilliant military talents,
but he had an instrument shaped
for him that was already far and
away the best army in the Greek
world,
the best army of the Greek
world had ever seen,
perhaps as good an army as
there ever existed in the
ancient world.
This is the great
achievement of Philip,
or at least that was a basis of
it.
He was not merely a hoplite
battle leader in the old style.
One thing about Philip that was
very important was his
temperament, his mind,
his approach to warfare.
He simply didn't accept the
notion of defeat.
He didn't accept the notion of
making some kind of a deal
except on his terms when he
found it necessary to do so.
He's famous for having said
after a temporary setback
against one of his opponents,
Philip has said,
"I have not fled,
but I have retired as rams do
in order that I might make a
stronger attack the next time."
He really lived that principle.
Nobody ever defeated him
permanently.
If he had to accept a temporary
setback he immediately went to
work to repair it through a
variety of means,
military, diplomatic and
whatever else he had available.
But as I'm saying at the
moment, he crafted this great
grand new army,
supplied,
led, and organized quite
differently from what I have
described to you in the past as
the standard Greek practice,
which was essentially the
hoplite phalanx,
and as you know,
in the course of the
Peloponnesian War in the fourth
century new gimmicks were added
to that and different devices
were contributed to it but still
that was true.
Now, Philip absorbed all the
things that had been going on
before his time,
but he also made fundamental
changes in the way that things
worked.
To his phalanx,
and I was going to say,
of grim professional
soldiers--now,
that I think is in itself an
enormously important thing.
We have something new on the
Greek scene, an army which is a
national army.
That is to say,
it is made up of Macedonians
serving Macedon,
under a Macedonian king,
but they are not the citizen
soldiers that we have examined
in the case of the polis
and its phalanx.
They are hoplites in that
phalanx.
They were professional
soldiers so that their full time
job was being an army;
they did not spend their spare
time back on farms.
That means Philip had to pay
them a salary for them to
perform.
At the same time,
they were not a mercenary army
in the traditional sense.
They were not people gathered
anywhere who fought for whoever
hired them;
they were very much Macedonian
soldiers.
Something we can understand in
the United States today--an
unusual thing in American
history beginning only a couple
of decades ago.
We have that sort of an army.
We have a professional national
army, and I think this is an
objective statement,
it has become the best army in
the world.
There are many reasons for
that, but I would argue one
reason is that if you can have
the sociological background to
permit that kind of an army,
you are in very good shape
indeed.
That's what Philip was able to
create.
The kind of loyalty,
the kind of commitment,
the kind of association with
the cause that only a citizen or
a subject of a king can have,
along with the skill,
and the practice,
and the conditioning that is
part of being a professional
soldier.
So, he has this phalanx made up
of these professionals that I'm
talking about,
but he added to that a group of
people called the foot
companions, pezetairoi is
the Greek word,
who were the biggest and the
strongest of all the Macedonians
and to that group he added the
companion cavalry,
the hetairoi themselves,
the companions of the king,
and of course these were the
noblemen and they became
personally attached to Philip in
a special way and were the most
effective,
the most reliable forces that
he had, an elite core,
and here again is something
different.
The cavalry will play a
much more important role in
fighting than it ever has in the
Greek fighting of the past.
One of the great geniuses of
Philip would be to create a
combined force that could use
cavalry and infantry and some
other subordinate forces I'll
tell you about in a minute,
jointly together,
to carry out a rather complex
military plan.
These, of course,
are these hetairoi,
our aristocratic horsemen,
heavily armored on strong
horses.
That's very important as well,
because if you're going to use
them as shock troops,
which he did on many an
occasion, all of that has to be
in place.
Then there was another
contingent of infantry with
probably less body armor than
his phalanx had,
who were called the shield
bearers, hypaspists,
and they occupied the center of
the Macedonian line next to the
phalanx.
These fellows were usually
the first infantry forces to
follow behind a cavalry charge
if that's the way Philip fought
the battle,
charging a cavalry at the
enemy, and as the enemy provided
opportunities,
these shield bearers,
these lighter armed infantrymen
would find their way and expand
the holes, opening the way for
the major blow to be struck by
the phalanx.
I'm describing one kind of
battle that could be fought.
The thing about having this
kind of varied military force is
that you could have different
tactics for different battles
and Philip does things
differently on different
occasions.
This group of
hypaspists,
lighter infantry,
provide a crucial link between
the first mounted attack and the
follow up by the phalanx proper.
On top of all of this,
you have a professional core;
again, they're all Macedonians
remember, made up of really
light infantry.
That is to say,
slingers, archers,
javelin men in the traditional
mode that the old Greek armies
had,
but didn't make too much use of
typically and so that rounds out
the composite army group made up
of these different kinds of
forces,
and these missile men I guess
you could call them,
supplied both preliminary
bombardment with the things they
did to help harass the enemy
phalanx,
but also they provide a kind of
crucial reserve support.
If you need to throw some
forces into a suddenly important
piece of the battle these guys
were very mobile and you could
order them into that place to
support whatever was going on
there.
You can see how infinitely more
complex this was than the kind
of fighting we've talked about
before.
Now, these Macedonian
contingents I've been describing
do not represent a fragmentation
of forces as might possibly be
thought,
but rather a diversification
and a sophistication of arms,
as one historian puts it,
a symphony not a cacophony of
professionally equipped men.
Philip's contribution to the
history of western warfare,
therefore, is not so much
tactical as it is
organizational,
creating this complex
organization that could have a
variety of tactical uses.
Now at first,
the equipment and the tactics
of this Macedonian phalanx for
itself did not differ
considerably from the
traditional hoplite columns of
the Greeks,
but he then subsequently made a
very important change.
Now, he does keep the
spear, the pike that was the
fundamental weapon of the old
phalanx.
But it was lengthened from
being let's say roughly eight
feet long to fourteen feet or
so.
Now, you cannot hold a
fourteen-foot pike with one
hand.
This is a two-handed weapon;
if you're going to control and
use it effectively that's what
you have to do.
Well, if you're going to have
two hands on this thing you
can't have that hoplite shield
that was the characteristic of
the old hoplite phalanx.
So, the shield shrank and
became unimportant.
You realize that once you do
this to your hoplite phalanx,
it can only function
successfully as an aggressive
force, if you see what I mean.
You can't just take blows;
you have to be delivering blows
all the time.
The greaves and the
breastplates,
and the heavy head gear were
replaced either with leather
which was lighter,
or various composite materials,
or else abandoned altogether.
So, you can see these hoplites
don't look anything like the
hoplites we're accustomed to.
The central idea,
however, of a fighting mass of
infantrymen remained
predominant.
In fact, integrated with and
protected by such diverse
forces, Philip's phalanx of true
pikemen,
their lances now allowed the
first five, not merely the first
three ranks to strike at the
enemy,
was both more lethal and more
versatile than the traditional
hoplite columns.
The historian Polybius,
who wrote in the second century
B.C., but you have to realize he
was a contemporary of Macedonian
soldiers,
who were still fighting
fundamentally in the same way
that Philip had created,
so he knew what he was saying.
He, for instance,
he describes the great battles
between the Romans and the
Macedonians that occurred late
in the third and into the second
century.
So, he even saw or certainly
knew about the new phalanx,
the Macedonian phalanx,
tackling the Roman Legion and
fighting it practically to a
standstill.
Polybius says that infantry,
who faced such a storm of
spears, as he puts it,
might have as many as ten iron
points concentrated on each man.
Nothing Polybius concluded can
stand up to the phalanx.
The Roman, by himself with his
sword, can neither slash down
nor break through the ten spears
that all at once press against
him.
Well, he has to face the fact
that the Roman Legion did defeat
one of these phalanxes in the
course of the third century,
but I think if you look at the
details you realize that there
was nothing inevitable about
that defeat.
Circumstances in battle
allowed the Romans to win,
because it put a premium on the
great advantage that the legion
had over the phalanx;
namely, that it was divided up
into smaller fighting units that
could adjust and move about the
field much more freely than the
fighters in the phalanx of the
Macedonians.
That was certainly an edge that
the legion had,
but there never was a time when
a legion fighting a good
Macedonian phalanx could predict
that it would win,
much less that it would be any
kind of a walk over.
Of course, against the kind of
forces that Philip faced,
it was all the more likely to
produce a Macedonian victory,
because those were not Roman
legions that they had to face.
Now, if you're going to
have a national mercenary army,
a national army made up of
professionals,
that means it costs money in a
way that the old phalanx system
did not require the expenditure
of funds very much.
So, Philip, early in his
career, had to gain control of
sources of money and he did so.
Early as king he immediately
had to put down his opponents
from within Macedonia,
but he also did what I suppose
Macedonian kings always had to
do on their accession,
they were surrounded by what
the Greeks called barbarian
peoples and these barbarian
peoples were always fighting
against the Macedonians and
trying to push back their
frontiers and so on.
So Philip turned against these,
the Illyrians and various other
peoples, and did an excellent
job of defeating them,
driving them back,
establishing the boundaries
where he wanted them.
In the process,
accomplishing two very
important things.
One was to establish his
credentials as a great general
and leader for internal purposes
and for military purposes is in
a sense of winning the
confidence of his soldiers,
but also it meant that his own
stature in general and the
reputation that he gained both
among enemies and friends grew,
and finally the last point,
this kind of fighting allowed
him to train his army and to
create this army,
and to make it as excellent as
it became before he had to face
more formidable forces than
these.
So, now he has won the loyalty
of his nobility to a degree that
no predecessor ever had.
He now has these barons who are
so independent,
happily, gladly serving him and
being rather in awe of him,
and the army in general was
devoted to him in a way that was
unprecedented for the
Macedonians.
Now, with this weapon
largely forged he was able to
begin serious expansion in the
Greek world.
A critical step rather early in
his monarchy was his attack on
Amphipolis, and you will
remember Amphipolis was this
Athenian colony that was such a
big deal for the Athenians that
they were prepared to do almost
anything to get it back,
but they never had thoroughly
been able to get it back until
recently.
So, now he took
Amphipolis--what was more
important than anything for him
was that who held Amphipolis was
likely to hold Mt.
Pangaean which is right near
Amphipolis, which contained gold
and silver mines that were
producing wealth as they had
been for centuries now,
and now that wealth was going
into Philip's pocket and he used
it for the purpose that was most
important,
chiefly for paying for that
army that I have been talking
about.
We are told that this
produced about 1,000 talents a
year for Philip's use,
and that's about the same
amount that the Athenians got
out of their empire.
So, you are talking about lots
and lots of money and this
explains the economic capacity
that gave Philip the chance to
use the kind of army he had.
But he was extraordinarily
skillful at the game of
diplomacy.
I say game, because he treated
it in that way.
Diplomacy, I think,
for him was an extension of
military forces by peaceful
means.
It's kind of a standing
Clausewitz's definition of war
on its head.
Who was it?
Sir John Fortescue,
I think, it was in the
fifteenth century defined a
diplomat as a man sent to lie
abroad for his country.
I think the spirit behind that
pun was certainly right for
Philip, that for him diplomacy
was a way for advancing his
country's interests by whatever
means that he possibly could;
he was very good.
One of his very great
skills was precisely to lie in a
very convincing manner and,
of course, it's much easier to
get people to believe what you
say if you have got the
strongest army anywhere in sight
in case you should be so
impolite as to say "you're a
liar."
I think that must have assisted
him.
But what I mean is Philip would
come into conflict with some
polis or some
poleis over some
territory that was in dispute or
whatever,
and they would say Philip what
are you trying to do,
you seem to be trying to
conquer this territory.
Oh no, no Philip said,
I have absolutely no interest
in this territory,
I've got other things to do
that are much more important.
Those Paeonians in my
background require my attention
and when the other guys would
calm down he would calmly take
the place that he had left
alone.
I'm reminded,
and I guess after the Second
World War, in fact even before,
there were some scholars who
made the analogy between Hitler
and Philip,
and Demosthenes and Churchill,
it's not the worst one.
It's very imperfect,
but it's not the worst analogy
possible, but I remember Hitler
kept saying before his strength
was great enough simply to
launch a major war he would say,
if you give me this that's all
I'm interested in,
that is absolutely my last
territorial demand in Europe,
and then in a few months he
would then seize Austria or
something like that.
So, Philip reminds me of that,
because he did such things from
time to time.
It's just too much to tell in
terms of the detail of his
career, but let me just hit a
few highlights and give you the
direction in which it was going.
The first business that he
had to do after he gained
Amphipolis and the wealth of the
mines was to gain control of the
shoreline of the northern Aegean
Sea,
and that meant of course his
own Macedonia,
which he had,
but also eastward into the
region of Thrace.
He began precisely to gain
control of those places.
It was in 357 that he took
Amphipolis and that meant that
he had to clash with Athens,
because as I say,
Athens had never given up its
claim to Amphipolis and kept
trying to get it back,
because of its value to the
Athenians.
What we will see is war between
Philip and Athens on and off
until the final victory of
Macedonia.
It's a period of quite a
stretch of time in here in which
that's going on.
On the other hand,
it's never a full scale war
with Philip trying to conquer
Athens.
How could he?
He's still outside from a
territorial point of view,
outside the entire old Greek
world.
But he can cause all the havoc
he wants to in the northern
Aegean and the Athenians will be
unhappy about it;
they will send forces up into
that part of the world to
contest Philip's expansion and
that's where the fighting goes
on.
But the Athenians are not ready
to take him on and really try to
stop him from going where he
seems to be going.
What they do is they respond
when he does something that
annoys them or that they're
worried about.
Sometimes they go out and fight
him, but usually they don't,
or sometimes they do and they
do so too little and too late.
That's the story of the
relationship between these two
powers throughout this whole
stretch of time.
With the expansion of
Philip in a variety of
directions, he increases his
revenues wherever he conquers.
He gets down into Thessaly,
now we're talking about
territory that the Greeks
consider to be Greece and Philip
is now gaining more and more
control of that area.
The revenues grow and he even
builds a navy and begins to
challenge Athens and others at
sea.
He attacks Athenian commerce
when he is quarreling with the
Athenians.
The Athenian position in
general is badly weakened in the
years between 357 and 355 in
what the traditional historians
call the Social War.
That doesn't mean that they
fought over teacups or anything
like that, "social" derives from
the Latin word socii,
which means allies.
It was a rebellion against
the allies of Athens in the
Athenian Confederation,
which really frightened the
Athenians, and kept them busy
putting it down for a couple of
years.
There is some debate among
scholars today as to how
oppressive or not was the
Athenian rule of its empire.
The more recent scholarship has
suggested that the Athenians
were not really very oppressive,
which leaves for,
I think, for them an
uncomfortable question,
if that's true why was there
this rebellion in the years 357
to 355?
We just don't know enough to
talk details about this,
but I think there can be no
mistake;
the Athenians abused their
position of power and leadership
in the empire.
They didn't do so as thoroughly
and completely as they did in
the great Athenian Empire of the
fifth century but that was
largely because they couldn't.
They never had the power,
they never had the financial
strength to be able to impose
their will as the earlier empire
had,
but they did what they could
and they did enough to annoy
their allies into such a
rebellion.
Athens recovers,
they win, they put down the
allied rebellion,
but they are weakened in the
process.
In 356, there breaks out on the
mainland of Greece,
what they would call the Sacred
War.
It's the old business of who
controls the Delphic Oracle.
The neighbors,
Phocis, Locris,
frequently take advantage of
opportunities to gain control of
the oracle and to deprive the
priests of their control of the
region.
The priests then call on other
Greeks traditionally led by
Sparta but not always to beat up
the people who have taken over
the oracle's place and drive
them out and restore it to the
priest.
Well, this is another in that
theory, in that series of
events.
Thebes and Phocis are involved
in a war over Delphi.
The Phocian general is the only
time he crops us in this story,
Onomarchus apparently was an
outstanding military leader and
defeated the Thebans and even
pushed into Thessaly,
and that brings Philip into the
picture, because Philip has been
expanding Macedonian power into
Thessaly from the north coming
south.
So, Philip takes his forces
and he pushes the Phocians back,
defeats Onomarchus,
sends them off.
Now, here's the question.
Is this good or bad for the
Greeks?
On the one hand the one thought
would be well,
sure he's just put down this
fellow who has arrogantly seized
the Delphic Oracle,
but now who is there,
who is sitting in Thessaly,
this great big new army.
Is he going to be a menace to
the Greeks in general?
Well, we who have had a chance
to know how it came out and know
that it did.
But at the time people were
divided, some say oh my heavens
this is a thoroughly aggressive
man at the head of an army that
looks incredibly strong and he
has terrific ambitions,
what are we going to do,
against those who said,
no it's okay,
he's okay now,
he's happy, he doesn't want to
do anymore than that.
Let's take a look at
Athens, which will necessarily
be the leading figure in the
opposition to Philip such as it
is.
Thebes, last time we looked at
Thebes, Thebes had reached a
position of power perhaps
greater than that of Athens,
but you remember the deaths of
Pelopidas and Epaminondas simply
did not allow Thebes to continue
to have that vitality and power
that it had before.
It's still a very strong state.
Its hoplite phalanx is still
formidable;
they still have great ambitions
and so on, but it turns out they
don't really have the capacity
to take the lead in such a
business.
The Athenians do and they are
very much concerned about what's
happening.
But it's not the same Athens
that we saw in the height of its
power in the fifth century.
Relatively speaking,
it is a very poor place indeed.
It is, however,
still the number one naval
power in the Greek world and
therefore very important.
Let's take a look at the
internal life of Athens a little
bit and notice some changes they
will have some significance in
terms of what decisions the
Athenians make.
There is something that was
introduced -- we don't know just
when -- it might have been late
in the Peloponnesian War it,
might have been afterwards.
It is called the theoric
fund, and it gets its name
apparently because there was a
payment to the Athenian citizens
of the price necessary to pay
for the ticket to see the great
theatrical festivals that went
on twice a year in Athens,
which had apparently
degenerated pretty much into a
dole, into a kind of a welfare
fund for the very poor.
It did not amount to a stunning
amount of money,
but given the poverty of Athens
in general,
any fund of money could be very
significant at critical moments,
especially on issues of
national defense.
But there was a lot of
argument, a sort of a democratic
party, the party of the
underprivileged or whatever,
always insistent that
everybody's supposed to keep
hands off the theoric
fund which should only be used
for its welfare state--I'm
embarrassed to use such a term
because of course there was
nothing like that in the ancient
world.
Just for that portion of the
national income that was used to
alleviate the worst poverty they
wanted that untouched,
but when the state was under
siege, it was under threat,
it was--had to go to war,
so it seemed to some
politicians, they needed money
to do it and say let's take the
theoric fund for now
while we have this necessity and
there would be a fight about
that.
You remember the Athenian
Empire in the fifth century?
Never had a money--not never,
but could generally handle its
money problem because it had
this great income from the
empire,
say roughly 1,000 talents a
year coming in.
That was not true.
So, that if Athens wanted to
send an expedition anywhere,
they had to levy a direct war
tax;
it was called the
eisphora.
They had done so two or three
times during the Peloponnesian
War.
As far as we know they had
never done it before that time.
We have stressed how unnatural
direct taxation was in the Greek
world, but here that's what they
really had.
They had to pay this
eisphora, if they were
going to conduct a military and
naval campaigns that they felt
were necessary.
In fact, it used to be true
that individual Greeks back in
the fifth century could pay
their share,
what was assigned to them for
the eisphora,
individually,
but now they were so few people
who could do that they organized
groups of taxpayers whom they
called symmories who
would share the burden.
It makes me think that it
probably sank further down
the--sort of the wealth class of
Athens.
More people I guess were now
paying taxes than before.
In the fifth century the
only people who paid taxes were
the very wealthy and now that I
think was attenuated as people
who were not so wealthy had to
pay something as well.
Another thing is that we find
the Athenians using,
as a regular thing in these
campaigns that they will have to
fight, mercenary soldiers.
I don't mean mercenaries of the
Macedonian kind,
the kind that Philip was using.
I mean hiring a band of
mercenaries who might come from
anyplace in Greece.
That was because the Athenians
were reluctant themselves to go
out on expeditions.
Nothing could be more different
I think from the way the
Athenians behaved in the fifth
century when they were all over
the joint,
as you remember,
in 457 that inscription that
talked about those died from one
tribe all over the battle.
They were proud of it and they
never ran short of soldiers
willing to do this kind of
thing.
The assembly voted it and the
people win.
Not now.
The Athenians are reluctant
to engage in these activities.
Our main source for complaint
about this is Demosthenes,
who much of the time is
pleading with the Athenians to
recognize the danger presented
by Philip and for them to take
the necessary steps to check
Philip before it was too late.
What he asked them to do
repeatedly was to first of all
vote the money that was
necessary to support the
expedition and then not to hire
mercenaries but to serve
themselves in the fighting,
and he did not win those
arguments very often.
There were in Athens throughout
this period people that we would
call in our own jargon hawks and
doves;
people who were ready to fight
for these purposes and people
who were very reluctant to do
so.
The people who seemed to be the
most reluctant to do this were
the upper classes,
of course, because war meant
taxation and they were going to
do the bulk of the paying of the
taxes.
It may well be--I don't
want to make too much of this,
Philip, wherever he could would
install oligarchic governments
in places that he ruled.
He was not interested in
democracy;
he was not a friend of
democracy.
There were some Athenians who
had never given up their hope
that an oligarchy could be
placed into Athens,
instead of a democracy.
They would have been doves and
more.
I mean, there is a pretty clear
indication that Philip did in
Athens what he did in other
states as well.
He bribed important Athenians
to be champions of his cause and
the people it's easiest to get
this to work with are people who
agree with your approach,
who on your side of the
argument.
So, there was some of that.
I mean, there was a real
difference of opinion as there
always is.
We should be very aware of
it and in recent years this is
the kind of thing you see.
Some people in society seeing a
great danger out there that must
be prepared for and confronted,
others thinking that that is
overblown, that that is too
pessimistic, that there is no
such great danger or that it can
best be dealt with by
negotiation and conversation,
and anything but fighting,
and that was the situation in
Athens.
If you were hostile,
if you were a member of the
hawk faction,
you would say your opponents
were deluding themselves about
the degree of the danger and
that Philip was a very special
kind of a menace.
If you were a dove you would
accuse your opponents of being
alarmists, excessively afraid
and worse.
Of course, both sides accused
each other of much worse things
having to do with their
characters and so on,
as people always do.
The first statement we have
of Demosthenes,
who will emerge as the dominant
hawk for most of the time that
he is doing business in Athens
is in 351,
when he delivers the speech
that we call the First
Philippic.
He delivered a series of
speeches attacking Philip and
warning the Athenians of the
danger presented by Philip.
To this day,
philippic is a word in English
which means a strong attacking
piece of rhetoric against some
individual or some nation.
He charged the Athenians with
having created the great danger
that they faced by making Philip
into a great man through neglect
by their refusal to stop him
when it was relatively easy to
do so.
They should send,
he thought, a fleet,
a good-sized fleet to serve in
the northern Aegean Sea and to
stop Philip's expansion and to
stop Philip period.
He urged them,
and he will do this over and
over again.
Don't hire mercenaries,
enlist for service yourself,
vote for war tax,
and those of you who should pay
it should do so.
He lost the argument.
The Athenians did not take
that action that he recommended.
Philip, pretty soon after that,
attacked the Olynthians;
you remember Olynthus is an
important state on the Chalcidic
Peninsula;
it has been a very significant
state back in this century you
remember when the Spartans went
up there to defeat the
Olynthians who had constructed a
league of their.
Well, they weren't out of
business yet.
So, Philip went after them and,
again, Demosthenes urges the
Athenians to get involved and to
prevent Philip from taking
Olynthus an the Chalcidic states
and gaining control of the
northern Aegean Sea and all the
danger that that presented to
Athenian interests.
Again, he loses the argument.
He delivers three Olynthiac
speeches which have the same
character as the one I've
described, but the Athenians do
not do it.
In the year 348 Olynthus
falls.
That city and the other cities
of the region were destroyed.
You remember this is not a
typical way in which the Greeks
dealt with defeated states,
although heaven knows the
Peloponnesian War had seen
examples of it,
but it was a very,
very harsh kind of warfare that
Philip carried forward.
He destroyed the cities
physically, he enslaved what was
left of the population and so
this was a message.
I think it wasn't just that he
had a cruel temperament,
though I suppose he must have
had that too,
but it was meant to be
exemplary.
It was meant to say when Philip
says do this,
do it, because if you don't,
he will crush you and this is
what will happen to your city
and to you.
That's an old technique.
We know that the Assyrians used
to do that way back in biblical
times in which they would
deliberately be as brutal and
cruel as they could be,
and having done so would
broadcast how brutal and cruel
they had been,
in order to encourage other
states to behave appropriately
in the future.
Hitler had used those same
tactics early in the Second
World War when he destroyed the
city of Rotterdam from the air,
completely not military
whatsoever.
It was obviously intended to
terrify everybody who might want
to resist him.
So, that's what Philip did up
there.
Finally after further fighting
of one kind or another,
the Athenians and a number of
other Greeks make a treaty with
Philip.
It is called the Peace of
Philocrates;
he was one of the negotiators
on the Athenian team.
There really didn't seem to be
much disagreement among the
Athenians as to the desirability
of this peace,
even Demosthenes who is
normally opposed to anything
like it, felt that it probably
had to be done,
and I think that just reflected
the realities of the
distribution of power and also
of the willingness of the
Athenians to do anything more
than that,
and so there is this period of
the Peace of Philocrates in
which the Athenians make a
defensive alliance with Philip.
There things sit when
another development raises the
panic button,
I think, for Demosthenes and
some others.
The Sacred War,
there's another Sacred War
going on.
This time the people who want
to restore power to the priests
invite Philip to lead the Greek
forces in the Sacred War.
That is a very big deal.
First of all,
it recognizes the Macedonians
as Greeks in the truest sense of
the word.
It should have been,
probably was,
a major source of satisfaction
for Philip and extraordinary
glory in the eyes of his fellow
Macedonians that the Greeks
should have done this.
Not only accepted them as
Hellenes, but asked them to save
the Oracle of Apollo,
the center of Greek worship
there.
So, he takes his army,
he runs into the Phocians,
blasts the Phocian army and
does what he was asked to do.
In the process,
when it's all over,
he decides that from now on
Macedon and King Philip will
take not just one vote on the
council that governs the Delphic
Oracle.
I may have mentioned it to you
earlier in the semester,
the Amphictyonic Council,
the council of those who dwell
around Delphi.
He took two votes on that
council, and he made himself
president of the Pythian Games--
you remember these panhellenic
festivals.
There were four great
panhellenic festivals,
Olympia, Nemea,
the isthmus of Corinth,
and the one at Delphi which was
called the Pythian Games and
here is this barbarian from
Macedonia not only sitting on
the council but being the
chairman,
holding the position of honor
as all the Greeks gather for the
Pythian Games.
Well, this must have had an
enormously intimidating effect
on many in the Greek world,
and it becomes more and more
Athens that has to take the
lead, if anybody is going to
resist.
The Athenians were concerned;
at least those who were not
determined to accept the course
of events.
Phillip was very careful with
Athens, for this there was a
very good reason.
They had a special strategic
set of advantages that nobody
else in the Greek world had,
and that Philip didn't have an
easy answer for.
Athens was a walled city
which had proven itself capable
of defending those walls.
You should realize that up to
this point in Greek history,
nobody has demonstrated any
kind of ability of taking a
walled city by force,
the only way you can take a
walled city is by surrounding it
and starving it out,
but you remember now that the
Athenians have a navy and walls,
they can't be starved out in
the same way.
So, taking on Athens,
if you really want to take the
city, is a job that's very
difficult indeed.
Of course, the Athenians have
their navy which makes that
true, but also allows the
Athenians to do you harm in a
way that other states cannot do.
So, all of that means that
Philip is not about to make a
headlong assault on Athens,
but to try to have his way by
going around Athens somehow.
He tried to win Athenian
support through his usual
technique of soft words,
explaining how he had no
aggressive intentions in areas
that the Athenians were
interested in,
even though he had already
demonstrated that that wasn't
right.
Also by working Athenian
politics, by bribing Athenian
politicians to be on his side
and using every device he could
to make it harder for the
hawkish people to have their
way.
Demosthenes from here on in is
determined, and determinedly
against Philip,
spending all his energy and
time trying to get up Athenian
support and then,
indeed, to put together a
coalition of states besides
Athens to resist and fight and
defeat Philip.
Indeed, he is more successful
than he was before,
because the danger from Philip
is obviously greater,
so that more Athenians can see
it that way.
The league he puts together
includes Euboea,
Megara, Achaea,
Acarnania, Lucas,
Phocis, and finally Thebes.
Now, that's a pretty good
trick.
Phocis and Thebes are
traditional opponents,
but they're both in the league
and what that tells you is that
those states,
and especially those states
which are in central Greece,
closest to where Philip is
located with his forces into
Thessaly and so they now see
that there is a great danger
from him and they join in an
anti-Philip coalition.
He doesn't go at them
immediately directly;
he goes to war but he does so
up in the north on the shores of
the Aegean Sea.
He moves eastward--this is an
enormously clever thing to do,
towards what the Greeks call
the Chersonese,
the peninsula which we call the
Gallipoli Peninsula,
the Hellespont.
Philip wants to gain control of
that, because if he can control
the Hellespont,
it's the old story,
he can cut off trade,
he can starve Athens out and it
would hurt others too but Athens
would be the main attack.
So, he moves forces to the
Thracian coast,
taking various cities there,
and gaining more and more
territory towards that end,
and then he goes all the way
across to the Bosporus to
Byzantium, modern Istanbul,
and he takes that city as well,
and, of course,
you can cut off trade,
if you can control the
Bosporus.
So this is very,
very serious for Athens and
it's on this occasion that
Demosthenes delivers his third
Philippic making the same case
as he has been making all along,
and only doing so but I think
with even greater intensity and
this time with more
persuasiveness,
because more and more Athenians
understand how serious this
menace has become.
Small point but not so
trivial that the Athenians were
able even to enlist the support
in language at least by Persia.
If the Greeks are going to
fight this guy,
it would be awfully handy if
you could get the Persian
support.
As it turns out,
the Persians don't do anything
of importance in resisting
Philip,
but it shows you how
Demosthenes and those Greeks who
agreed with him were attempting
to put together as strong a
coalition as they could to try
to stop him.
Forgive me.
Don't pay too much attention to
what I'm saying but I'm
constantly being reminded of the
behavior of the European states
just prior to the Second World
War,
and in place of Persia I think
we would have to put the United
States of America,
which was out of the game and
sort of constantly trying to
stay out of the game,
powerful isolation of sentiment
in this country,
and people in Europe,
some people urging that
everything be done to get the
United States into the game and
others reluctant to do that.
It wouldn't have made any
difference, nothing would have
gotten the Americans to take an
active part against Hitler at
that time,
and I suspect there was no
chance that anybody could have
convinced the Persians to do
anything at this point either.
But the Athenians do send a
force and it's a good size force
and it does a very good job,
and they drive Philip back out
of some of the places that he
has conquered,
which I think is interesting to
think about.
It's not obvious that if the
Athenians had gotten their
collation together earlier,
and if they had done the best
they could, it's not obvious
that they couldn't have defeated
Philip.
There's this terrible danger
that we will all become victims
of a fait accompli,
what happened obviously had to
happen, it couldn't happen any
other way.
No, I don't think that's right.
We certainly don't live our
lives as though that's true,
and we shouldn't allow
ourselves to imagine it's true
in retrospect.
The fact that the Athenians
could have such success against
Philip as they did at this
moment is evidence that that was
by no means a hopeless cause.
Once again, a Sacred War breaks
out over Delphi.
Again, the Amphictyonic League,
this time of course having as
its president Philip invite
Philip to lead the forces of the
Sacred War.
The Sacred War has been
declared against the town near
Delphi called Amphisa and that's
the force that he's going to use
against it.
Philip moves down from
Thessaly, arrives at a place not
very far from Delphi called
Elatea on one side,
and the other side at
Thermopylae.
These are the roots to get down
into central Greece.
Once you go through those
places you are right next to
Boeotia, you are a couple of
days from Athens,
you're right in the middle of a
position where you could do
terrific harm.
When the Athenians received
the news, there really is panic.
Demosthenes tells the story.
Now, Demosthenes is a witness
who is excellent because he's a
participant, contemporary,
that's great,
but you've got to look at him
with a certain amount of
skepticism because he's a
participant.
He's a guy who held a certain
point of view,
he was very active in politics,
he has strong views on
everything, his reputation
depends upon how you look upon
what he did.
So, you must understand that
when he tells us these things
he's telling it form his
perspective.
It's very much like Winston
Churchill's histories of the two
world wars in which he played a
very large part,
even in the first but certainly
in the second,
and it's not that he lies,
it's not that he deceives,
but when you read those stories
you read them as Winston
Churchill sees them and you have
to be alert to them.
There's a wonderful--about
Churchill is a wonderful story,
apparently true,
that when Churchill's book on
the First World War came out--I
forget the title;
let's say it was called "The
Great War," which it wasn't.
The former prime minister,
Arthur Balfour,
who didn't like Churchill at
all is supposed to have said,
"I see that Winston has
published another book about
himself and called it The Great
War."
The enemies of Demosthenes
might say the same things about
what he says in some of his
speeches.
But later on in his career when
there was a big battle between
him and his chief opponent,
Demosthenes' friends were
asking the assembly to vote him
a crown.
It meant a crown of leaves,
not of gold,
but the honor for things he had
done for Athens and his
opponents thought that what
should be done for Demosthenes
for what he had done to Athens
is to throw him off the
Acropolis.
So, there's a great debate that
we have both halves of.
It's in that debate that he
recounts the things he has done
for Athens, why they should be
grateful to him,
and this moment is one he
points to.
He tells about the news came to
Athens that Philip was in
Elatea, and he says,
we all gathered there first
thing in the morning and the
place was full.
If you remember that
passage I read to you from
Aristophanes about how things
usually were in the Athenian
assembly,
where everybody came ambling in
late, no problem,
nobody was in a hurry,
no he says,
everybody was there.
When the prytany for the
day, the president of the
meeting said,
who wishes to speak,
no one, no one raised their
hand.
Then I got up and gave you guys
the good advice that followed
and all that stuff.
But I think we can't doubt the
essential truth of the
situation, that there was just a
terrible fear and no idea how to
cope.
Demosthenes then suggested what
steps should be taken to resist.
One of them,
and he was able to do it now,
was to use the theoric
fund to supply the forces that
were necessary.
Secondly, to do something that
was quite an achievement from a
diplomatic point of view,
to make an alliance with
Thebes.
Ever since the late 370s
Athens had not been allied to
Thebes, it had become alarmed
that Theban power had joined
even with Sparta against the
Thebans,
but here as we're into the very
late 340s, early 330s,
he makes an alliance with
Thebes so that what is surely
the strongest ground force on
the side of the Greeks against
Philip will be there,
namely the Thebans,
and the Boeotians in general.
Finally, in 338 the Battle of
Chaeronea takes place in western
Boeotia and the result is a
victory for Philip.
The battle itself was by no
means a walkover;
it was very close.
Our accounts of it make it
clear that there was every
possibility, even then,
even though the Spartans
weren't there,
even though Philip's forces
were at their peak.
The Greeks might have won that
battle, that's a very important
thing to remember,
but they didn't.
Philip won and that was the end
of Greek freedom.
Thereafter, the states all had
to bow down to Philip in terms
of foreign policy.
In many cases,
he actually interfered in their
internal autonomy.
He established garrisons at key
places in the Greek world,
including Chalcis and Euboea,
Corinth and Mount Ambracia in
the west and they were called
the fetters of Greece.
It was like he put a great
chain across Greece to show and
demonstrate, and make real his
control.
Athens was forced to abandon
the confederacy,
its own confederacy;
they were forced to make an
alliance with Philip.
He constituted in 336 the
League of Corinth with himself
as president.
It was an offensive and
defensive alliance.
Philip was commander in chief
and he could tell everybody what
to do, and they would have to do
it.
This truly was the end of Greek
freedom.
As it turned out,
Philip was assassinated in the
same year so that he never was
able to demonstrate how he would
carry on once he had that power.
The business of the
conquest of Persia,
if that was in the mind of
Philip, had to be left to his
very young son Alexander,
who I think was eighteen at
this point.
So, that gets us to the
interesting question of
history's judgment on these
events,
and especially I think the
interesting person is
Demosthenes, and as you read in
your problems collection,
the nineteenth-century German
historian Droysen and the German
historians of that time in
general had no doubt about the
judgment.
It was very negative about
Demosthenes.
After all, what was Athens
anyway?
According to Droysen it was
ein advokaten republic,
it's the lowest blow anybody
could deliver,
a republic of lawyers.
What Demosthenes was trying to
preserve was kliene
Stdte,
the world of small independent
states,
a contemptible term in the eyes
of Droysen and his fellow
nationalists.
German, you remember had
just--I forget the date of his
writing, either it had already
been unified by Bismarck or
nationalists were demanding that
these little states all be
brought together into a great
German empire and that's where
Droysen was.
The future,
Droysen said,
was with Philip.
Demosthenes was a reactionary
trying to retain things that
were--whose time had come and
gone.
What was needed was the
unification of the ancient
Mediterranean and this was a
step in that direction.
Why was it necessary to have a
unification of the ancient
Mediterranean?
As would finally be
accomplished,
not by Philip and Macedon,
but by the Romans,
because it was all part of the
great plan without which there
could not have been
Christianity.
Christianity could come to the
world and dominate Europe,
because it had been made into a
single word by virtue of the
Macedonian and Roman conquest,
and Demosthenes in his small
minded petty way was standing in
the way of that.
Yes, there were admirable
things about Demosthenes,
but his behavior and his policy
was quixotic,
because it was hopeless.
I think this is my reading of
what Droysen really is saying;
he lost so he must have been
wrong.
Winners are always right or
else they wouldn't win.
Now, I think we can evaluate
that in a different way.
If we think about a different
situation, I've been thinking
about it all along and telling
you about it,
which is let's take a look at
Winston Churchill who had been
called by historians the
Demosthenes of that time.
The man who had been calling
attention to the danger from
Hitler and trying to rally
support and really treated like
an idiot until finally the
knife,
the dagger was at the throat of
the British and only then,
and with great reluctance did
the British put him in control.
Now, if we look at his
experience and what he did I
think it's illuminating.
The difference between heroic
victory and disaster can be
terribly thin.
Taking office at a low point in
the fortunes of his country and
its allies, Churchill made a
famous speech,
which just breathed defiance
when there was no physical
justification for such a
position.
He said this,
"I have myself full confidence
that if all do their duty,
if nothing is neglected,
and if the best arrangements
are made as they are being made,
we shall prove ourselves once
again able to defend our island
home.
To ride out the storm of war
and to outlive the menace of
tyranny, if necessary for years,
if necessary alone,
we shall go onto the end,
we shall fight in France,
we shall fight on the seas and
the oceans,
we shall fight with growing
confidence and growing strength
in the air, and we shall defend
our island,
whatever the cost may be.
We shall fight on the beaches,
we shall fight on the landing
grounds, we shall fight in the
fields,
and in the streets,
and we shall fight in the
hills, we shall never
surrender."
Yet England came within a
hair's breath of losing that war
and suffering the horrors of
invasion and occupation by Nazi
Germany.
In fact, had Hitler and Guering
continued bombing the RAF's
landing fields and ground
facilities as they began to do
with the Battle of Britain,
instead of turning away from
that and using their planes to
bomb cities and scaring
civilians,
it's very clear to me that
Germany would have won the
Battle of Britain and control of
the air,
which would have made their
success inevitable.
Now imagine that it had gone
that way;
in that case,
Churchill's bulldog
determination,
his refusal to accept what was
a relatively generous peace
offer after the fall of France,
would seem in retrospect the
wrong-headed defiance of a man,
who brought his people low by
his own intransigence.
He would have been treated,
I think by history,
as some kind of a gallant fool,
some kind of a brave imbecile.
But men like Churchill and
Demosthenes know that those who
love liberty must fight for it,
even against odds,
even when there is little
support, even when victory seems
impossible.
In spite of the outcome,
it seems to me that the stand
of Athens and its Greek allies
at Chaeronea may have been in
words that Churchill used in
another context,
"their finest hour."
Thank you very much.